pas de jujubes ou de chocolat au
cannabis pour protéger les enfants
la décision de québec pourrait changer
la donne
à ottawa et à gatineau dans l'industrie
du cannabis le consommateur va aller là
où le produit est disponible
et oui peut se le procurer le plus
facilement possible et le plus
rapidement donc ceci étant dit si on est
près de la frontière possiblement que
les consommateurs vont vouloir aller en
ontario ottawa va légaliser les nouveaux
produits du cannabis le 17 octobre
mais il faudra au moins 60 jours après
cette date pour qu'ils se retrouvent sur
les tablettes
cette employée d'un magasin de cannabis
de tahoua s'attend à l'arrivée de
nouveaux clients québécois
même si elle dit comprendre les raisons
de la décision québec je pense que c'est
vraiment on apprécie vraiment la
décision
l'impact pourrait aussi être économique
des acteurs de l'industrie du cannabis
craignent une chute des investissements
du côté québécois notamment en raison du
choix de couche-tard d'investir dans une
entreprise présente en ontario et ça
nous affecte directement et on voit que
couche tard qui a investi ailleurs qui
était l'expression une entreprise phare
au québec avec une présence partout dans
le monde est obligé d'investir ailleurs
le marché noir pourrait lui aussi saisir
la balle au bond selon des sources
policières
en avril le service de police de la
ville de gatineau a mis la main sur une
importante quantité de drogue dont
plusieurs jugements et des mots fun au
cannabis plus encore plusieurs sites
illégaux de vente de produits cannabis
comestibles comme celui ci ont vu le
jour récemment à ottawa et il livre à
gatineau
les gens doivent être conscients que
le marché noir existe l'ampleur de ce
marché noir pour les produits
comestibles présentement il est très
facile pour un consommateur d'aller sur
un site internet et de commander des
produits en ligne les produits qui ne
sont ni contrôlées ni protéger les
dosages et sont exponentielles québec
justifie sa décision sur le cannabis
comestibles à 10 ans qu'il faut
absolument réduire l'attrait pour les
jeunes mais aussi réduire les risques
d'intoxication involontaire ici
guillaume dumont radio canada ottawa